Hello. I'm Ron Vale
and today I have the pleasure to be
speaking with Dr. Christiane Nüsslein-Volhard
and Dr. Eric Wieschaus
who worked together as junior faculty
between 1978 and 1981
and made historic discoveries about genes
that are involved in controlling
embryonic development. Work that lead
to the Nobel Prize in 1995.
So thank you very much for joining us
today and perhaps we can begin
by describing some of the work
that you did and the discoveries that you made.
Nüsslein-Volhard: I started working with flies with the idea to
find morphogens by mutations in their genes.
At the time, people were trying to isolate
factors which would alter or change
embryonic development and they did that
by cutting and slicing experiments, essentially.
Transplantation. Centrifugations. All these things.
And all these experiments had lots of artifacts
and at the time, in our institute, they were
people who did genetics, in bacteria,
trying to identify genes involved in
DNA replication and I figured if
one would try the same methods
to development: making a mutation
in a gene which is really important
for embryonic development
then you should see it in
phenotype and the gene would
be encoding something we are looking for.
I mean, drosophila genetics
had been done but mostly on
the structures of the adult fly.
Only very few people looked
at embryos at the time.
And Eric was one of them.
Wieschaus: Yeah.
Nüsslein-Volhard: I met Eric in Walter Gehring's lab
in Basel where he was already
finishing his thesis on
Drosophila embryology
and I found that extremely exciting
and learned a lot from him.
And then we joined later.
Wieschaus: Yeah. I think you've,
your sense of the problem was a
bit more, was actually really directed
towards morphogens. Whereas
I came into the field, I think,
because I had, as an embryologist,
didn't have the molecular training,
even the genetics training,
In a certain sense, I had.
I worked on flies all my life
but what really fascinated me was
watching embryos develop,
and that these things happen
that are reproducible and
mysterious but in some way had,
by that time, we knew, had to
depend on specific proteins
and therefore specific genes.
If genes are important
for morphogens, if they are important for
everything an embryo does,
then if you knocked.
If you set up a program where
you are going to randomly
mutagenize genes, knock them out,
in set of little inbred lines because flies are diploid,
and then look at the consequences of
thousands and thousands and thousands of mutations
to identify which mutations
in which genes therefore affect processes
that are discrete and understandable in the embryo.
Just about what we did.
We struggled to do it for several years
to figure out how we could do it.
Nüsslein-Volhard: It took some time until we
focused in on this project.
Wieschaus: And how to do it.
Because people had that mutagenesis.
Ed Lewis had figured out how to use EMS
to induce mutations. That was a huge, wonderful thing
about flies. People had worked on them
so we knew how to do stuff.
But how to do it on the scale that
we thought was necessary to actually
to get enough of the pieces of the puzzle
to get a picture of what was
really happening was hard.
Nüsslein-Volhard: One of the things we did
which contrasted the previous work
is that we figured that the result of
embryonic development would the larva
and not the fly so we should
look at larval structure and not at fly structures.
And this is what he did in his
thesis and then we turned to
developing methods.
How you could really see the segments
in a living embryo and also in a
prepared embryo and use
this pattern of the cuticle
which is displaying the segmentation
as landmarks for identifying mutants.
We established 12,000 inbred lines
which had on average had 1 or 2 mutations
in them and looked at the consequences in the
embryonic pattern in the larva, in the cuticle
and we discovered 120 new genes
which when mutated, caused strong
changes. Distinguishable, visable changes in the pattern
which was a small fraction of the entire
genome, about 1% or so.
Wieschaus: So we were lucky there.
Nüsslein-Volhard: Most of the genes, when mutated,
don't cause any morphological
visible alterations. Embryos just die.
They look normal. But we'd pulled out
those that did not look normal.
Wieschaus: After that initial screen,
to bring most of those loci to a point of
publication still took 3 or 4 years.
To go from, we did the screens,
we published an initial paper in Nature
on the small class that affected segmentation
but the broad group of 120, 130
genes that affected all aspects of
embryonic development, to map,
to characterize, to assign to complementation groups
all of that took 3 more years.
Vale: So the two of you worked very closely
together during this time
and I'm curious: what features of
about you as scientists were similar
that allowed you to really synergize in the
type of work you did and
in the discoveries that you made?
:Nüsslein-Volhard: We share one feature which is
important. We are very good
observers, both. I think, hardly anyone who can...
Wieschaus: It was terrible. It was wonderful but I mean
Nüsslein-Volhard: We really matched up on
this and it's rare that you match up
with other people in this special
quality that you really
recognize minute details
and I think we are equal
in this respect and it was
maybe really exceptional that
two people who are so
good in observing shared
this project. We had this
dissection scope where we looked
in from two sides on the same
embryos and then we
and one said "Ah look. Look at this!"
and then "Yes I've seen it already." This kind of thing.
We really, we had some phenotypes
which were so subtle and we both
saw them and then we discussed
is it worth keeping?
Is it not worth keeping?
We had to kind of have these cut off
criteria where one bristle too little or
one hair too curled?
Is it enough to be significant?
We did agree in most cases.
Wieschaus: There was of course a kind of
not quite a comp...
well maybe yes, a competitive
element in that because we were
so equally matched in the ability to see
phenotypes that were phenotypes
that, you know, you have this huge
mound of slides and you are looking
through them one at a time
and most of slides are garbage
because you just did embryos
from mutagenized stocks and so
the whole trick was to sort,
put the slide on and look at
it and recognize that there was a
quarter of the embryos that showed a
discrete phenotype. It could have
happened that either one of us was,
despite of our observational abilities,
could have been temporarily distracted
and the other would see the
phenotype first.
Nüsslein-Volhard: That kept us awake.
It was very important.
It's a tough job and it is extremely tiring.
When you look all the time.
It's like when you are in a museum
and you are there in the museum
and you are content. But when someone
goes with you and says
"Look at this, look at this"
then its much, much easier.
Wieschaus: And you did actually
develop a special relationship
to those loci that are mutant lines
that you saw, that I saw, first
and she didn't see until three seconds later
on the slide. So those became really
like they were mine and you also have.
These will stay secret. These are genes that
are out in the public domain now and so
you don't necessarily want to know
who are Janni's special children and who
are my special children in that respect.
Vale: So Janni, I was struck by one of the
the quotes in your Nobel Prize biography,
which said that "We realized the screening
for embryonic mutants would be very rewarding
and that we were the only people
in the world that could do it, "
and I’m just curious what that
meant and if you could elaborate on that?
Nüsslein-Volhard: True. No?
Wieschaus: At the time, certainly
but that is the kind of statement
you have to justify so now is your moment.
[Nüsslein-Volhard] You mean it's too arrogant
in such a biography?
No, it was strange. Listen Ron,
I remember when we had done the screen
and we were thrilled and we thought
"Shesh this is exciting" and we had
a poster of 48 pictures of
these mutants on the
second chromosome and
they were extremely significant,
the phenotypes, and
we knew that we couldn't
interpret them properly but
we knew each of them has
to be explained and put
into some framework before
we understand how embryos are made.
So it was a great achievement
we were sort of proud about it, sure.
And we presented this in a
drosophila meeting where there
the biggies of the field were
present and they stood in
front of this poster and "Oh, what's this?"
and then they turned around
and went away.
They couldn't understand it.
They didn't even
They had no…they didn't even say "Wow! Oh!"
I mean some hostile. Others
were completely insecure,
didn't know what to say
And this was the response.
And this was sort of...
This is why we say "Well,
only we could have done it."
I mean, if no one can
understand it, it means no one else
could've done it too.
Vale: So I gather that the two of
you first met in Walter Gehring’s lab although
you only overlapped for a short period
of time. Was there something
about when you first meet
each other that you realized you had
similar interests or similar intellectual curiosities?
Nüsslein-Volhard: So I went to work
in Walter Gerhring's lab actually
Wieschaus: In January.
Nüsslein-Volhard: In January 1975
and Eric had just finished his
thesis and that was full of
people who came to work with
drosophila without having
worked on drosophila before
and Eric was one of the
very few people in this
lab who knew something
about embryos. He
knew something embryos
and it was another woman,
Jeanette Holden, who
knew drosophila genetics
and so I tried to get as much
out of them as I could.
Jeanette left after half a year
later and Eric left a couple
months. He had already started to
move to Zurich but I tried to
and he came back because he
had a collaboration with
people and I just tried to get
as much knowledge out of him
as I possible could and
that was a time for me, for which I was
eagerly picking up whatever I
could get and it was
so exciting. I dreamt of flies
when I closed my eyes I saw
fly embryos.
Wieschaus: We used to met and eat
dinner together and talk
about stuff. I think we talked about
science. We talked about art.
I was, you know because I grew up in
in Alabama, I was like...
Nüsslein-Volhard: I knew nothing about
imaginal discs. I had a hard time
understanding your thesis and was so...
Wieschaus: I had a hard time understanding my thesis!
Nüsslein-Volhard: But we had common interests too. I
I mean music and drawing and arts.
So both of you then did your postdocs
and then you both got hired
at pretty much the same time at
the European Molecular Biology Lab.
Was that just a coincidence or was
there some planned synergy
that brought the two of you together?
Nüsslein-Volhard: I was looking
for a job after two years in
Walter's lab. I had an EBMO fellowship
which run out and he and I
didn't hit off together too well
actually and I wanted to leave but I
didn't have a place to go
so I applied to the EMBL,
which was new at the time,
it was the second year or so,
and I didn't get a job because
people said "Well maybe she
can't do that alone,
she is just started working with
flies and in case some other fly
people come to the lab
yes, maybe but not alone."
And then I first got a
another fellowship and went to
Freiburg and spent a year in
Klaus Sander's lab and
embryologist, insect embryologist,
and then I got the offer from the
EMBL and they had in the meantime
asked Eric. You had been asked hadn't you?
Wieschaus: I was asked to...
Nüsslein-Volhard: You hadn't even applied.
Wieschaus: I hadn't applied.
Nüsslein-Volhard: He didn't have to
apply. He just was asked
would you be interested in
coming to the EMBL.
What a luxury!
Wieschaus: Yeah, it was pretty cool.
Nüsslein-Volhard: I was struggling and I dreamt of
being out of unemployment and
didn't know what to do and I wrote
letters to people I didn't really
respect and begged them to
give me a job. It was really
tough because I had
started working with flies
only when I was the age of 32.
I had done a long PhD,
a good, interesting PhD, on
bacteria genetics, no, bacterial
molecular biology and then
switched to flies with great
enthusiasm but in a short time
in the lab and in Walter's lab, I had
published a paper in contrast to
all these other brilliant
postdocs who took them much
longer to publish something
but I didn't get a job for that
because this was not a field for which
it was not a big field and people were...nah.
I didn't get credit for what
I had done before so
for me it was a tough time
I must say. And then
when I got the job at EMBL
I was of course thrilled and
together with Eric, oh great fun, yes!
But they treated us in a very
"maybe we can take this risk
it's not so expensive. let's take
these two guys and put them in
the smallest lab" and a very
small, we had a...
an office space together
two by two meters.
Wieschaus: We discussed a lot.
Nüsslein-Volhard: But not in this phase.
The lab was really so small that
it was a bit hard but we didn't
bother to much and we just tried to
to get our microscopes working and
going and we got a technician,
shared technician, and a
girl who took care of the
flies and then we had a good set up.
we had no students. It was also no
discussion of whether you get
PhD students. We just were
on our own. So we were
a two headed group without a body, essentially.
Wieschaus: Essentially for us,
being in the lab, having the
facilities that were available
at the EMBL, not having to worry about
teaching, not having worry about
money, being in this small group
where the most obvious thing for us
to do was to push forward
this common experiment.
That was enough! I mean
there we were and we could talk.
We talked with each other a lot
and then it we went off and you knew
other people. It wasn't totally enough
and it wasn't that we were totally
isolated but the reason why it worked
was that we were intellectually
dependent on each other.
Vale: So I was wondering how you're
experience might be relevant
for young people today who
are obviously trying to start their own careers
and achieve their own independence
but also want to collaborate with
one another?
Wieschaus: The good thing about
obviously the good thing about
collaborations is when they work
is that you do have
two people, that if they are
really good and they, even
if it's not truly yin and yang,
complementary, it is an overlapping
synergism that is hard to predict
but I think that's why you want to
why you are really lucky in your
career if you are able to collaborate.
Nüsslein-Volhard: And in this case,
I think that none of us could have done
this project alone and it got much richer
with two of us. Also the quality of the
analysis, I think, is not just
maybe could have discovered
120 genes but how you describe them
and how you put them in order.
I think that was really much,
much, much better with us
two together compared to each of us
singularly and I think it's the best
project I’ve done in my life.
Wieschaus: I have to obviously say
that it was the great time in my own career.